Social psychology is an area that many students find endlessly fascinating.
Which isn't surprising, because we're humans. We're social creatures. When
we're infants, we need other people to take care of us or we wouldn't survive.
So it comes as no surprise that other individuals actually can influence how we
think, feel, and behave. And that's what social psychology is. It's the study
of how other people affect our thoughts, behaviors, and feelings, and in fact,
as you're going to see, it's not only the actual presence of other people that
can affect us. It's the perceived presence. So people who aren't even there can
affect how we think, feel, and behave. Let's go to Susan for more detail about
this lesson.